hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we were at Game
three and Magnus is down one point so he
needs the he needs to win the game to
get back into the match and if you
didn't win the game then it's game over
for Magnus ding will win the match and
face Hikaru in the in the finals so
without further ado let's see if Magnus
sticks with what he what he was playing
the London system or he goes for
something else so we have d4 by Magnus
again we have Knight to f6 Knight f3 d5
and F for once again the London system
is on the board with East six biding end
Knight B to d2 so the usual not going to
stop we have c5 and now III Queen to b6
putting pressure on the B to pawn and
now rook the b1 defending we have Bishop
to d6 and it's it's a position that's
reached quite often Knight to c6 Bishop
to d7 are all known Monsieur but Bishop
to d6 is a new move so as of move 6 we
have a completely new game dink wants to
trade out the dark square Bishop we have
c3 by Magnus not interested in this and
here ding just trades off everything
captures captures and captures captures
but this gives Magnus an excellent ee5
outpost for for his Knight so nice the
c6 first putting some pressure on the d4
pawn not allowing any any quick Knight
to e5 plants and now Knight the b3 so
the d4 point is nicely protected and the
dingos for a5 he wants to kick away one
of the defenders of the d4 pawn so it
makes it it makes it harder for Carson
to get an a e5 outpost for his Knight so
with a3 and now just a for biting
Knights the c1 preparing to shift the
night over to a2 and then to b4 or c3 if
needed and the Bishop to d7 being
continuous development with Knights the
a to end now Knight to e4 now dings the
one who gets an excellent outpost for
his Knight
well Knight to c3 challenging this
Knight and now the Queen to c7 biting an
extremely strong move asking Carlsen
what do you do with the f4 pawn how do
you defend it so do you go g3 or do you
do give up the f4 pawn so here after
some minute consideration across and did
go for g3 he defended his pawn and now
ding just goes for Knight captures and
c3b characters in 95 going for
to be 3 square so-and-so look to see one
getting getting drugged preparing the
rook for to go to see 2 nights the
beasts reading just continued with his
plan and the rook to c2 now so the the
rook is looking kind of weird there but
if it works why not we have Queen to d6
now that everything is nicely set up for
ding he wants to grab the a3 pawn and
there there's not much my magnets can do
about it you can go Queen see one you
can go Queenie one the night covers both
of these squares and you have to give up
da three pause so Magnus continuous
development Bishop to d3 and ding grabs
the pawn Queen captures on a three we
have castles by Magnus and now dink has
now passed a pond so if Carson doesn't
figure out how to deal with with some
sort of an attack on the King side the
the past a pond should prevail
so f6 biding first not allowing any
jumps with the night and now rook to e1
so it's a question is this one of those
positions where it's actually okay to
play f6 or not
dink castles here and we have Queen to
be one now so what do you do here there
might be some some plans of rook date
you or maybe rook to be to fall that
Bishop to see to add to maybe try and
win back the pawn but it's hard to say
if winning back at the pawn and trading
off a lot of pieces will do do good for
Magnus as he has with Dwight pieces and
he really needs a win so I don't think
he was he's very interested in the pawn
so Queen back to d6 nothing wants to
move this night and start pushing his
passport but rook c2e2 now doubling up
rooks and E on the e-file and it's not
it's not all that clear how do you get
the night away and start pushing this
pawn so first h6 binding he creates some
some further weaknesses on the King side
but it is needed if you want to if you
want to play something like f5 not all
night to the g5 and here Magnus takes
this opportunity to play f5 himself
which ding allowed as he created some
weaknesses here he's preparing Knight
the h4 so Dean goes for the pawn we have
a captures on a5 and not Knights to h4
going for this pawn here and now Dean
just goes for
rook 88 which seems like it's it's
giving up too much material but ding has
it has it all figured out here
Magnus goes for night characters on f5
which which comes with an attack on the
Queen we and now if you move the Queen
then just nice to e7 check will be
extremely strong so Bishop captures an
f5 with rook captures ne8 first now of
course if you recapture you just you're
just lost so nice the d2 this is the
move that the dig being finds and it's
an extremely complicated move as the
Queen is under attack if the Queen moves
and doesn't defend the bishop then you
can play Bishop characters on d3 Knight
to f3 check is an idea which will win
the rook on e 1
so here before anything at first rook
captures on a fade with check we of
course must start with this and here
didn't played King characters on f8 if
you go for Queen captures and F a then
Queen to b5 is very strong going for
this point this point and also this
point will will fall with check and also
you are just the defending your bishop
on d3 so this would be the idea and
after Knight f3 check King h1 Knight
captures here anyone you can play Bishop
captures on a5 for example and still
there are all of these targets still
remain here Bishop to g6 will be an idea
in the future and the white position
will be great so instead of Queen
captures we have King captures biding
and now now comes a move that is well
there is only one move here that allows
Carlsen to continue the game with some
advantage so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this idea now
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you that were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that the
black King does not have all that many
squares and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show its Queen captures
on b7 now the point is if you go for
something like Bishop captures on d3
you're immediately lost Quinn c8
checking of seven and Queen to D a queen
t8 will be made as the pawns prevent the
King from escaping
so being instead goes for Knight to f3
check we have King to h1 and now Knight
captures on e1 and Magnus just captures
the bishop with Bishop characters on f5
there is a slightly better disgusting
engine line starting with Queen to a8
check but these
things are too hard to spot and after
king f7 now you capture on f5 and now
you want a tempo as the king is on f7 so
whatever black does let's say three you
have this Bishop to h7 move which will
win you the d5 point you're just gonna
play Bishop here with check win the pawn
and be much better however that's not
for for us humans to find Magnus played
Bishop captures on f5 and here ding-ding
is doing very well he just needs to play
Queen to e7 and the game continues
however being or seemingly decided to
return the favor favor and he played
Knight to f3 so once again feel free to
pause the video and now try and find I
move that wins the wins the game for
Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
supporting and spotting the move that
we've already discussed and for those of
you who just wanna enjoy the show it's
well Quinte a check is nice but better
of the g6 ends the game immediately as
there is no defense against Queen to f7
mate you could you could waste a few
moves ding play Knight to g5 so it
prevents it for a moment but after Queen
to c8 check
it was in this position that dinkler and
resigned the game and the Magnus cross
and equalizes the match and now we'll
see what happens in game 4 will it be a
decisive game or will it be will be a
draw and then we go into the blitz mini
matches so here you resign because there
is nothing to do you either give up the
Queen or you go here and then it's just
Queen to e8 checkmate so after see the
Queen c8 he resigned and the water water
what a weird weird weird matchup first
Carlsen blunders that terrible terrible
King h7 moved ending returns the favor
here with Knight to f3 allowing better
up to g6 so really crazy stuff both of
them must be very very nervous about
this matchup but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Stephen Bukowski now Alexander
Deutsche squeaky-clean
Simon Heath and one Vincente Alvarez for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos ER thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you I will see you in heaven
the rest of your Saturday